joey is
up next and joey's with us in louisville
kentucky hi joey how are you
hey dave dave and dr d thanks for taking
my call our pleasure how can we help
all right so i'm on baby step 3b um i'm
getting married in november
and i have a car uh it's paid off
i pay cash for it but it's a it's a
german car it's an audi
and i just put new tires on it that cost
me a grand
last month and then i have something
going on with my brakes that i just got
quoted
nineteen hundred dollars to stick oh
beer break i think i'm getting a second
opinion yeah
that's that sounds like a dealer to me
no that's that's that's too that's like
a mechanic but they're telling me to go
to the dealer because the parts are so
expensive
wow hmm the car has the car has 40 000
miles on it
and um what's your car worth
uh i could get rid of it for 17.5
okay all right so what's your question
my question is should i fix these brakes
and sell it
and then i only paid 21 for the car and
i could get 17.5 so do i
do i fix this and sell it because down
the road i don't want to drop two grand
every time something goes wrong with
this car
well i mean it is a more expensive car
to work on than a domestic car
or your uh or a more standard honda
toyota thing i mean
an audi a mercedes a beam are gonna cost
more to work on
uh in in any case a 1900 brake job blows
my
mind but um uh so
i mean if you're tired of that stuff and
you want to move into a
a quote more reliable less expensive to
maintain vehicle that's fine
but don't use this as an excuse to move
up in car we're gonna you know buy a 17
500 car when you sell a 17 000 500 17
000 500
car that makes sense yeah exactly i
guess so
with me getting married and we're saving
for a house it's like
a 2 000 expense every other month it
ain't gonna
i don't think that's gonna happen but
you know
but it has exposed the fact that you
have an expensive car to work on
right so when it does break but i mean
you don't really we don't none of us
sitting here thinking you're gonna spend
two thousand dollars a month for a year
you're gonna spend twenty four thousand
dollars to keep this car running that's
not the case
audi is not a piece of crap they're a
good car but
you know but obviously there's some
expensive parts on that puppy
or something i am really gonna get a
second third and fourth opinion on this
i'm just not gonna
when something seems weird it's usually
because it's weird
right and that i mean both john and i
had a physical reaction when you said
1900
and you know we're not mechanics we
don't work on cars
uh but we both uh have enough redneck in
us that we've turned a wrench here or
there and so you just
you just kind of go huh i just know my
first two or three cars didn't cost 1900
for the whole machine man much less the
brake job on it
well that's true there's that too that
that gives you a head tilt but yeah
if you're going to move just move to
something that you know look for what
you're looking for is reliable and or
low maintenance cost
or both and there's no problem to do
that and you can move down a little bit
in car
but let's not move up in car because
that is working against your
uh in terms of cost uh it's working
against your
your goals your preset goals